[Musik]
guten Morgen B hes schlaft noch ich bin
schon
wach Z
Bundeshaus das spricht sch dafür das
irend verwal
braucht viicht hilft das wenn ich das
soehen got auf rickis Berg und ich muss
da viicht
daseminverwal riberg wo immer auft wird
mus sie so ein SK
machen stempfelf Zack und dann kann ich
da oder ja schade ich w eigentlich gerne
bundesus gangen aberberg bra mit
dringen wenn Weg V bundesbn der
schwammichammenhang mit der
Bundespolitik
zukünf al auf
[Musik]
rickisberg BST und da ob sind die Hüser
wo wir
[Musik]
m hallo hallo wartest du auf mich genau
ich bin Mona
sinin freut mich will kommommen da im
schlossgart RBerG für
psychischtig wo da wohnen genau und
schaffen okay super ich
verbringe genau mega du wohnst da genau
ich glaub du bist sogar auf
Wege okay
hey und was ist das für braen wir das
ich
ze ja okay also freue mich im he für
Mens mit
pychisung vorbereitet alles das ist Mona
min der Schwamm gehus vom Schlossgarten
da P Bewohnerin und Bewohner FT national
und ständw
ab
ganze Tag da ja
F
kan ja ihr bra ich
brach also auf später dank der Arbeit
vom Georg und der andere da 24 zu ihrem
WT der schlossgar
rickisberg von der größte Heim für
Menschen mit berächtigung im Kanton Bern
rund
2Ü schaff und leb da in verschiedene
Wohngruppen
hallo ich
wohne genau super mit dem sin wohnen
noch 1 andere Menschen da und für auch
ich
ja Zimmer ist nicht groß aber der
Empfang herzlich danke viel was ist
jetzt das für Wege was für L mir
gemischt vom Alter mit verschiedene
betrachtigungsbilder aber alles
psychische betchtigungen ja meist
Form einfach so wie G in der psychis
berachtigung ist das einfach
so psychisch bechtigt was bist denn du
ja ja einfach epilepsia ja
und Brand B bis Verst aber eiglich nicht
mhm genau das ist ha Schw der
psychis
psychischtigung alles
vorstell im Schlossgarten sind Menschen
mit unterschiedlich Geschichte
erfahächtigung z.B dur Psychose
Depression suchterkrankige aber Mensche
mit geistige behindere
vi Klin hinter
sich Zim dachrieben DF wir h ja
sicher dar ja
al gestern ja also du h aufg g genau
ja ich B da mega frech und L was du h
der los ist ger Musik seh ich da genau
ja V allem t Sache also so also Schwizer
Sache drauf und Florian as und genau ja
und
und und da we besser die
wohne geht
so
besser ich f mich noch nichtk wohl ich
weiß nicht recht
wie mitbewohn
gegen mit mir glaub es B
[Musik]
wo oder mit wem wir wohneen kann man im
Heim nur bedingt selber
bestimmen auf dem Gang triff bekannt
Gesicht der
Georg oder ja du W da
oder okay du bist
selbständig Normalität kom wieder
auf und wier also das wier du well ja
genau so und dann B ich was ist den die
Geschicht vorher g we wo bist du alles g
ja ja
und
mit vor zi Jahr bin Kranken sch gegang
mit me Frau Krankheit
ich Fr ed D sch ja
jaang ah okay und jetzt bist wieder am ü
genau ja ja genau und ist denn das Ziel
sin weiß daso da sind dass die eiglich
vielleicht irgendwn auch selbständig
wieder Kön wohnen ja ja also da war dies
Ziel ja auf jeden Fall okay
ja der Schritt
Selbständigkeit im Gegensatz zu früh
heim
hfigstation Wege ler h kenenst du na ja
ich muss w
holen h
du mus
ich
ja ich soll W ich weiß aber nicht wo
s aber h den Nacht nicht
nicht
nicht nicht
ja das blöd mir so ja
aber das einfach so Absprache geht und
das ist wie nicht vorhersehbar genau ja
wie reagier ich gemerkt dass ich mir
allen überleg ich für Diagnose weiß du
all genau wer
was das ist mE schwierig
Thema Person
Versuch wenn ne verchaff dass sie mög
nicht
mit dem Background auf die
aber
ma
ich Chance mit wie sch
vorw aber länger das man schafft
kan passiert
einfacher Medikament ab ich muss was für
Medikamente sie
ab schmal
grad
automatisier wie man schaff dann versuch
WTF ja jetzt l mal wie mit dem
H tut mal leidell
ja
ja Bedürfnis
vor ja also
ich ja danke
vi Koch wird in zentrale jede Wege muss
Essen selber
gehol zum
Glück
WE dische Labyrint garantiert
verlaufen darf ich dir eine
geh
frag normal muss ich
die ja das Gut normal muss die selber WE
mit W bist mit Schatz ah das deine
Freundin ja wie heißt sie Stefanie
Stefanie und wenn oder wo h sie
keinet Facebook
ket Tag troff und tagp
S
lie alles
gestum Gute ein
gute und ich für dich jetzt das Kind h
du Gefühl ich bin irgendwie anders ich
bin komisch
oder
das das dich ausgacht oder so ja
oder D sie zu die Lehrerin sieupt dass
sie
gemacht müssen Sitz ob
siefang irgendein ich gar nicht mehr
reagiert
ja da gestesst als
Kind normale Pizza lieber
ich noch Nacht ist z für Koch undche
wird für die bewohnende aber das Hotel
soll
nicht ich Brück verarbeiten es gibt viel
begegn da wo man nichtön zeigen mit der
Dame im badmantel zum bpiel waso ich mir
als Psychiater vorgestellt hat mit der
Frau wo verkehrsumfall hirnverlzig
vit oder auch der ein wo mir voller
imbrunst verzählt V Idee der Klimawandel
mit Hybride solardoh stoppen das alles
got
am mit dem Georg abgemacht zum Bard
Spiel im Eldorado partyum vom
schlossg Z Bard ist nicht so
miesemacht
ge ist z Jahr im Schlossgarten er hat
dwachs Kind wo ihm enorm wichtig
sind h du mit de Kontakt ich Kontakt
jaef
Tag
Woch
das
und
Psychose
was denkst wie lang wie lang bist n da
und wennch
nicht
schbergpal im Sozialbereich super und
wer das WE wie ein Job finde ist da wie
das woh finde ja ja okay und W da
we jetzt momentch aber langsam aber noch
nicht sicher was passiert mit Arbeit das
schaffen jetzt
ABW also
W und so abwartte gut Arbeit gut ist wie
du g
Arbeit
wohne ja ja okay
[Musik]
ja
nor im Bard kein
[Musik]
Stich es wird wieder Tag über schlossg
riberg berü vfang sind
weg genau wie Schle
LUN ja gern ja
du
wieso Vater
gemachtah geh
[Musik]
m ja sind der Hans und
K
andere wel
unterwegs
aber ja gut
ja noch morgen schaff ich
Begle immer am Vormittag
schaff
[Musik]
Schl was trink einfach ja danke vi
mal du mal le gemacht we ne gar
keine die das es nicht das ist nicht
möglich
epilepsieelentsche
machen
nein wieso
nicht wirst du gerne leer
machen
ja
und
es
undter
unterstütz du
ma
möglich ist wie ja warum denn nicht
möglich einf W du will du W
bist mit
Sachen bra ja was WST den gern für
ausbildig machen Service Service Service
oder Logistik okay
ja du selber Gefühl du bringst die
Fähigkeit mit was brauch nicht
immer
let extrem viel
verschlafen ja
schaff
so das ist sehr gut
machen
ja
ja SP erfah dass es
nichtloss K machen im Moment
bel Bewohner vom schlossgart sich frei
bewegen
[Musik]
ang
extrem du denn da
Leiste
gr
hallo
änd sa Geld selber
verwalte im
mon 300 ja für was sind die 300
Frank Z
konzertbillet
ja macht die auf
14 kann mor ja was mir be de im Dorf so
richtig ffallt ist lag vom Schlossgarten
weg vom Dorf auf H der grundli der
Geschicht der Schlossgarten ist schon
140 Jahr Heim früher noch sind Menschen
wo n die Gesellschaft pas da ob soag
versorgt
worddeag probier gegil nämlich sich
hallo wir Ken
noch da ist
schön ja
ja ja du bist du bist schön
mit mit der Blume dafallt mir
[Musik]
also Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner schaffen
die unterschiedliche Bereich es gbt
gtnerei
er
wüscherei
recyclingteil
elektronikteiler
[Musik]
underei Kollegin sit
da der Frau mit der schöen Blumen im ha
schaff da auch zusan Willen me
Webstuhl du schast schon lang da ja
einfach drei mit ja genau und du Exter
genau
wständig 6 Jahre in gewnt wo ist jetzt
besser Gang da gewohnt h oder du
natürlichigag vieler ja vor über 20 Jahr
hat Susan letzt mal
alletzwischen mit Krise und
suizidversuchal die Klinik und
Institutionen
Star
best
mus selbständig wohne
Z
wieder
im schlossg
selberganisiert es umer rechtskonvention
unbrkwi unterche Mens mit
behinder Re wie alle
andere also so V der
hier schaff so ihr best
was Unterstützig aber nicht D mir
bestimmen über euch sonder dass mir die
Dialog kom mit euch und zw das Menschen
mit der
betchtigungass wo Sie wohnen mit W das
sie zammen wohnen also kann man sich woh
wirklich selber ist man frei ne wenig
das ist genau das wo
ja was aber sicher noch große veränder
Gesellschaft D das überhaupt umsetzbar
ist und realisierbar ist h ZAGs wie ist
denn wirklich die freie Wahlmöglichkeit
der Schwiz schon oder noch nicht
bedingt langach das
Versorgen genau und das Diskussion mit
dem Dorf Dorf
bändig nicht super und K nicht l D dief
super sie soür die
Sache alles was stört alles was
stört so also das ist sehr natürlich
schwarzwiß Herr Goldmann sag zum Wohnen
s Prozess oder ja ich bin eigentlich
lange Zeit verwoh so und vor ein paar
mon Möglichkeit sie
die probieren mit Begleiter zu wohnen
oder wo selbständig ist und das läuft
gut es geht mal drum dass es nicht gut
ist Institution aber d W dass ich
ausprobiere weil ich Wohnform stimmt für
m und die nacher
[Musik]
Thema ver spielerischeart mit dem
Quart
C das über dabei sein und selbst
bestimmen die eigene Meinung sagen der
Gesellschaft
h Ernst die S ja
also so viele der Klinik
Situation
SOEP
let über
die nein
doch2 hätte ich für
dich darf ich d
Fr
ja ist gute
Frage ichlich zurücklen mit le denke ich
kan das nicht erklären das so Gang nicht
ang so oder aber es ist Hal so g
oder ich weiß nicht werf einfach wenn
ich wenn ich die Begleitung nicht hätte
so jetzt bin ich sch 20 Jahr B da
oderg ja ja okay
aber stimmt für
mir ja einfach
einfach mein Vater Diplomat od immer
wieder
verschiedene die nicht einfach Wurzel
Fass od einfach mit der teren müss da
mehr J und da vier jah und hier vi jah
also und jetzt ich wenigstens denkelich
ist wie wie eine Baum wo plötzlich wchst
oder
Wurzel F oder
ja was der gilon genau für Diagnose hat
weiß sie nicht es spielt eigentlich
aucholle ich sensible reflektierte
Mensch kennengelernt wo da im Heim
Sicherheit und Geborgenheit gefunden
h im Studio einzimmerwoh verz mir
großeedchaftwe pro Woche fech so und da
h nachher da so eine Fechtmaske mit dem
tut man sich Kopf schützen zweimal in
der
Woche was bedeutet dir
da es bedeutet nicht viel also z mal ich
super Saag man man bewegt sich es FT
einfach mit mit mit der andere kamerade
oder mit den man fechtet und so geht
Bier trinken so ist immer sch mir die L
wo außerhalb von Psychiatrie also o ihre
Familie freizit so das das kan m n
inspirieren so du triff wo du sind der
Psychiatrie wo Familie denkst du
auchis warum ich das nicht od bist ja
also bim FCH undim Z trinken ich das
Problem nicht weil
dasich aber meistens
Nachhinein weiß die
hey Familie so und ich hier her und ich
bin halt in Wohnheim oder schlossgart so
aber es ist
relativ Kollege mit dir sehr for die
Frau die ich Krebs gestorben von ein
paar Jahr so und der ist jetzt auch
alleine so also es relativ oder
eigentlich das mit dem alle W ja das
bringst du
ich glaube es auch ich kann mir das so
so zuau ist viicht nicht geht jetzt mit
K schr so oder aber ich schätze wirklich
sehr dass sie dass sie hier sie oder
und tut Radio los Morgen und dann heiß
es überschwemmig in
Griechenland in andere Wald brennt und
so a frurchtbare Sache wo passieren so
so für mir ich bin dankbar für das ich
dass ich einfach ges bin
aber ich wünsche was ich mir auch sehr
wünsch bezieh od aber finde wo zu mir
passt das ich frage ist das
schwierig also bist du schwierig ja
also wie soll ich sagen
also es ist einfach od das Problem mit
der Hand zum Teil genau das VI denk h
vielleicht irgend B hygienisch weles
Problem oder d wenn ihr Partnerin hat
BF relativ
so ja einfach oder wo das
respektiert respektiert wie bin mit dem
mit
der wo se Grenze ander D andere Grenze
aber genau genau
[Musik]
ja
im schlossgart rickisberg ist sich
vieles am veränderen in Zukunft s Heim
wie das nur no ein Wohnform unter vi
sie und zweite W ichelernt besser mal
ein Schritt auf Mensch Z machen als eine
V ihm
weg
ja das richtig gut im F ja du bist
gut nein ich weiß es nie nein du ich gar
nicht was das da ist ja ja du wohnst
schon länger da J da ja und gut da
ja und H
f
schönen
Tag ich Gang nochal
werus zum Georg er ist im schlussportim
abpackenon der für die eigenössische
W
ja was
B sch Andes system a
sch Z ja also du bist jetzt für
nationalratswahle bist du am verpacken
ja genau geht
alles
so und
so ja also kom für mich ja jetzt wir
spannend ja die
die kontrolli drin ist und gut und
such da
gut stell
festes genau und
so
od ganz n nein du und wie findet man das
da bin ich total
ver ja genau aber da hoch Verantwort
oder ja jetzt probi
no
super das
istleran gut aber du selber W
ne
du abgestum
oder lustig oder du
W verpack Sel gar
nicht
ja die
andereere DF nicht
erfah 15000 Menschen in der Schwiz
nämlich
wechtigung ke Wahlrecht no wo die Recht
für alle noch nicht wirklich gich
[Musik]
sind
du ja ich bin Schwizer Bürger
eigentlich und und abstimm
so ja mich fragen mich was es bringt
oder
aber ja aber du du dur es geht sicher
viel aber so wo wrchtig s wo vielleicht
gar nichtmen mit der Politik also
ja genau aber und ich selber ich
eigentlich auch weiß auch nicht genau W
ich soll ab wähen das ja oder
ja hilfestellige Leiste und Hürden
abbauen für das setzt man sich im
Schlossgarten
rickisbergie mit dem Ziel dass Mensche
mit der psychische berächtigung me Kö
überk diesere
[Musik]
Gesellschaft zum Abschied vom
Schlossgarten triff m nochal mit dem
Severin und dem
gilon
genau also wie wie H de Tage gefallen
oder intensive Tag
sind so viel neue drück und am Anfang
ehis ich viel begegn B Gehör die jetzt
wenig
dazu ich
verhalte
undü oder
den passiert da also ja weß nicht me wo
du
da genau gich okay wirklich
ja träum we was ist was wä so
Traum auf sizilie also auswander das W
große Traum wenn
mal was wünschest du für dies
Leben
Freundin
undf in Serv
Logistik ja also das du wünsch dir
eigentlich dass wie irgendw so le fühen
wo du alles selber bestimmen genau ja
mer viel mal also DAO mir am
meistemt offheit für mich to
schön
danke mitle Schritt vorwärs zum
selbstbestimm le
wenn ih Gesellschaft das Paar Schritt
t sind Menschen wie der Severin und der
gilon hoffentlich bald auch mittendrin
statt irgendwo am
Rand